今天呢
我們來抽一個四六法
方舟出版社寄給我這本
破骨折的四六法
應該大家都耳熟能詳
應該也知道裡面
水分成兩個部分
四跟六對不對
但是在進入主題之前
我要念一下
以後你們這些出版社
要我推薦你們的書的時候
書要有我啊
推薦序也沒有我
這本書感覺跟我沒什麼關係耶
但是破骨折這個沖煮法
我覺得有點興趣啦
我覺得值得跟大家分享一下
我看到的一些內容
所以有出版社們注意哦
不要以為書寄過來
我就會介紹好不好
版稅我又沒湊
還是不要拍了啦
好啦!拍啦拍!
這個書我看
就是我的理解是這樣
大家都是拿4-6法來做手沖多嘛
但是其實我覺得
這個破五哲他自己呢
其實他喜歡的咖啡器材是很多元的嘛
他有參加過愛樂亞的比賽啊
手沖比賽是讓他得到世界冠軍的嘛
那得到世界冠軍的時候呢
他才當咖啡師兩年十一個月
所以像我們這種做十幾年的
沒有什麼了不起
人家兩年十一個月就達成世界第一
而且他才喝咖啡第四年
就得到世界第一
是他特別厲害嗎?
還是咖啡特別簡單呢?
可以思考一下
而且他開始喝咖啡的原因也滿有趣的啊
就是他最早是做IT顧問的
寫城市宅宅就對了啦
寫城市的馬農
然後
忽然間得到糖尿病你知道嗎?
糖尿病!他得到糖尿病住院的時候他想完蛋
我最喜歡喝可樂怎麼辦?
不能喝可樂
還有Google
可以喝咖啡啊
就是從那時候他才開始喝咖啡的
就買咖啡豆啊
買磨豆機啊
新手有沒有
新手都是隨便進一家店然後亂買
啊!有K模就好
然後欸!怎麼沖起來好難喝哦!
水又流不下去這樣
所以它的第一杯咖啡是
從非常難喝的咖啡開始起步的
所以它萌生了一個想法
這個想法是我很認同的
即便推薦人沒有我
我都認同
就是說它希望發現一種方法
是讓全世界的人都可以
很輕鬆的可以煮一杯好的咖啡
待會我們就邊做邊說明就可以了啦
我覺得
那我們這次也是用手沖
它最喜歡的咖啡器材是V60
但是我這邊只有01的
拿個02的V型的濾杯嘛
這個
這是什麼?
這是串流啊用串流也可以只要你喜歡用的濾杯就可以但是流速要夠順暢像這個折子其實也是超級順的蛋糕濾杯也是非常順的
這個叫極脆嘛
這個也是很順的
最近新出來的
T型流速會比較慢一點
如果你喜歡口感厚重一點的話
可以選這個
反正我今天是先用川柳
磨豆機!磨豆機的話呢
它是有說到磨豆機是一分前一分後啊
剛剛前輪不是有講嗎
它第一杯就是因為亂買
粉磨的太細細粉太多
沖不下去
味道很難喝啊
磨豆機要找那種
研磨出來
不是說細粉越少越好
比如說我們設刻度10
刻度10的這個部分分佈要最多
粗的也要有一些
細的也要有一些
你如果顆粒每顆都一模一樣大
其實味道也不會太好
就是它的粒徑分布要比較集中一點
這樣才會符合你的預期
然後有些刀是特別做給義式
比如說像Kinua
這個專門做義式的
你拿來做手沖
可能味道會比較擠
對不對
看個人喜好
我們這次用這個K-MAX好了
然後刻度通常我是射到8.5
這本書裡面呢
他會建議是用粗眼膜
我的想法不太一樣耶
我覺得
因為現在很多濾杯
它的流速是很快的
磨豆機的濾鏡是非常平均的
其實你要味道更豐富的話
我覺得你甚至往細一點膜也沒關係
只要它沖的時候不會阻塞
流速是順的就可以了
Pope澤沖的沖法是1比15嘛
所以它的咖啡粉會比較少
不用太糾結在這裡
因為其實我們看到書的後面
它還是有很多關於4-6法怎麼調整的
只是說4-6是一個原則問題
不是說一定要怎樣怎樣怎樣
50克水就馬上要停
60克馬上要停
好緊張對不對
假設是300cc的水
4是多少
總共分5次
對不對
120有兩次嘛
那我們可以拆開來看
一次多一點一次少一點也可以
兩次都60也可以
或是60、60、60、65次是不是300
也可以
所以其實彈性是滿高的
那我們今天用什麼豆子呢?
百花莊園紅都拉絲
水洗淺焙豆
這支應該滿好喝的
我不會完全按照書上
我會按照我自己的理解
希望我能得到世界冠軍的那個
精髓
裡面其實細節滿多的
有興趣的可以去買這本書來看
ISBN我會放在說明文裡面
雖然推薦人沒有我但是我滿認同普遍的想法的你要傳遞知識你也要懂得商業啊
出版社不是Innice的單位嗎?
這本書裡面也有告訴你微調方法
你如果碰到
比如說已經放比較久的豆子
你要怎麼處理啊
對不對
淺的豆子怎麼處理啊
其實每個咖啡店家或者是個人
你可以在這個4-6法的框架裡面自由發揮
假設是300cc的水
4-6怎麼分呢?
分5次抽嘛對不對?
每一份就是60
那前面2次呢
就剛好是120cc
就是剛好是4了
後面180cc呢
就是6了嘛
對吧?
前面這個4呢
一定要60-60嗎?不一定啊
根據你的喜好啊
你可能比如說第一次注水少一點
第二次注水多一點點
它有一個特色是
它會有進行兩次的悶蒸
然後悶蒸時間比較長一點
那後面有三段對不對
這個待會我們邊做邊講好了
反正我們就知道
前面兩段都是悶蒸
你可以60、60
50配70
50配70好像滿好的
好那我們就開始吧
分5次注水嘛
它的大框架是這樣
當然你也可以分2次
一次就4一次就6也可以
第一次50左右嘛
那我們就到
第一次是燜蒸水要輕柔
然後燜蒸一下下
對不對
第二次我們到70
這樣就120嘛
就符合它的規則
它前面兩次主要就是控制酸跟甜味
我記得我最早有一支影片是
教大家用湯匙
你可以接接看嗎
接著你大概可以知道
前段大概是代表什麼味道
大概這樣120左右
就是這樣
你悶蒸喝的那一口
甜味、酸味特別明顯
這邊有個重點哦
它第三次注水的時候呢
力量要大
要用力一點
這樣差不多180
有點好奇我來偷喝看看
只加三次喝起來感覺這樣
哦~~很濃哦
後面還有兩次嘛
第四次要稍微輕柔一點
第五次要更輕柔一點
這個感覺就是在調整它的濃度的
水溫是建議93
93我覺得有些時候是過高了
如果你的焙度比較深
或者是咖啡豆特別新鮮
可以略為降低一點點沒關係
最後一次是最輕的
好
這樣就完成了是不是很簡單呢來複習一下齁4跟6前面是我們想像成兩段的悶蒸嘛可以60、60也可以50、70
你自己去配
第一次做水不能太少
第一次至少要讓你的咖啡粉都濕透
對不對?
然後第二次
再悶一段時間
這樣讓它味道完全發展之後呢
第三次大力的把它沖下來
第四、第五次呢
是讓你
我的認知啊
是讓你調那個濃度的
所以我覺得在這個框架裡面
做的話應該
只要你不要落差太大
都會做出相對蠻好喝的咖啡
摩托家要注意什麼呢?
盡量找那種給手沖用的
粒徑分布平均一點的
濾杯找流速順一點的
水溫如果深焙的
溫度可以適當的調低一點
不一定要93度
93度對於有些深焙豆來說
有點太萃取速度過快了
這些都是可以自己調整的
OK!
我不是一個那麼喜歡用秤的人
因為我會覺得太忙了
我要關注咖啡的狀態
又要關注時間
那我會讓我失去很多自由的樂趣
如果你喜歡可以用
我覺得沒問題
可能會輔助到你
OK!那我們來看一下
他給我們打的預防針是
讓咖啡變有趣吧!
衝不好就是成長的機會了
所以你如果衝的不好
你也不用覺得
哎呀我是不是很笨很蠢
不是不是不是
萬丈高樓平地起嘛
一杯杯練習慢慢就會變厲害了
你看人家破古澤
第一杯也是衝的很難喝啊
喝咖啡第四年就世界冠軍了
做咖啡師兩年是一個月就世界冠軍了
對吧
還有各種咖啡也很有趣啦
做冰的啦
做各種常識的啊
配氣泡水啊
這些我們其他影片都有啦
有興趣的去我們頻道翻翻看看
好不好
今天這個
破骨折四六法
滿實用的
我覺得是一個很好的框架
我常碰到一些客人
就是會很擔心自己衝的不好啊
或者是什麼的
我覺得都是
你太把它真的太當一回事了
因為我覺得咖啡是很生活的事情
那你看這個破骨折
它是世界冠軍
它雖然訂了一個框架
但是它這個框架裡面的自由度是很大的
盡量按照你自己的想法
其實多做幾次就會變很厲害了
11月26號是我們虎記滿11年要12年的
你再來我們逛我買豆子
我們就多送你一個四合包好不好
讓你回去好好練習一下四六法
然後年底我們應該會推出
一個手沖的配方
好久沒做手沖配方
最近得到一些不錯的素材
好!今天影片就到這邊
4.6法我覺得值得參考一下
不要太被數字綁架啦
它只是告訴你一個原則而已
好!喜歡我的影片記得訂閱、按讚、分享
下次見!掰掰
以後吼!要我推薦你們的書
書的任何一個角落
要有寧波東街、小霸王才可以好不好